when it comes to technology Daimler
likes to equip its s-class with all the
latest bells and whistles but now the
car maker is aiming for efficiency as
well as luxury the s500 plug-in hybrid
offers the benefits of hybrid technology
seemingly without any drawbacks our
Chester I know Dyson over says the car
combines everything money can buy these
days luxury and green cred he says fuel
economy is given to just three liters
per 100 kilometers he's going to test
that out
on the outside the hybrid doesn't look
much different than the regular s-class
car experts might notice that this
s-class has an extended wheelbase
though there's one detail that's a dead
giveaway when I was looking and that's
the plug-in hybrid badging at the rear
says ride hood he notes that the trunk
space is smaller too due to the electric
battery while it displaces 96 litres of
cargo volume there's still 395 litres
left the s 500 plugins electric motor
generates 85 kilowatts of power alone
that's enough to propel the s-class to
speeds of up to 140 kilometers an hour
when combined with the gasoline engine
it offers a maximum output of 325
kilowatts the car could reach a very
respectable top speed of 250 kilometers
an hour in accordance with the emmys DC
driving cycle the plug-in hybrid S Class
consumes just 2.8 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers
I'm just listing final says it's nice to
drive the plug-in hybrid with the
windows down as in electric mode the car
is virtually silent the only sound you
hear is other drivers you can switch
between modes at the press of a button
hybrid mode is pre-selected letting the
vehicle calculate the most efficient
driving method automatically there's the
all-electric mode and there's a mode
which lets you save the battery's charge
for instance for driving around a city
that only allows electric cars
then there's charging mode which lets
the combustion engine recharge the
battery while driving tougher penalties
absolutely the battery bank on without
off let the interior of the plug-in
hybrid uses top-quality materials
worthy of an s-class to large display
supply the driver with all kinds of
useful information
it's a comfortable ride up front but the
backseat is truly luxurious
so nope so you're gonna say a car can be
deluxe deuces line hook the s-class
plug-in hybrid is currently only
available in the long wheelbase version
and has an electric range of 33
kilometers that doesn't sound like much
but it's enough for day-to-day driving
Germans who live in cities average 40
kilometers a day 20 kilometers to work
and 20 kilometers back and in the mean
time the battery takes just three hours
to recharge and all with zero fuel
consumption costing around 108 thousand
euros the s-class plug-in hybrid might
seem expensive but the extended
wheelbase version of the s-class v8 cost
just as much the plug-in hybrid is a
steel
an s-class that's fit for the future it
won't be long before it could be charged
as smoothly as it drives inductive
charging is all set to become a
household term Mercedes is already
factoring inductive charging in this
series development says Timo bomber the
system will be introduced within the
lifecycle of the present s-class it's a
lovely feature geared to maximum comfort
it uses induction coil to create an
alternating electromagnetic field from
within a charging base station in a
garage and a second induction coil and
the portable device converts it back
into electrical current to charge the
battery so no need to go around the car
no need to get out a cable and plug it
in just go to the garage and the
charging process starts by itself just
head to a garage getting the vehicle
turn the key and off you go
the s-class plug-in hybrid combines
comfort with impeccable green
credentials the only downside is that
the electric motor takes up a little
trunk space
you